we're told that glucose c6h12o6
reacts with oxygen to give carbon
dioxide
and water what mass of oxygen
in grams is required for complete
reaction of 25.0
grams of glucose what masses of carbon
dioxide and water
in grams are formed so pause this video
and see if you can have a go at this and
then we'll work through this together
all right now first let's just set up
the reaction
so this is going to be we have glucose
so that is
c6h12o6
it's going to react with oxygen now
oxygen in its molecular form
is going to be o2 and
what it gives is carbon dioxide
and water plus water
now the next question is are we balanced
do we have a conservation of
mass here and let's just go element by
element
so first let's focus on the carbons so
we have six
carbons on the left hand side of this
reaction how many carbons do we have on
the right hand side
well right now we only have one carbon
in this carbon dioxide molecule
so if we want the carbons to be
conserved we need to have six carbons on
the right hand side as well so let me
see if what will happen when i throw a 6
there so now my carbons are balanced
6 on the left 6 on the right now let's
look at the other elements
so on the left hand side i have 12
hydrogens
in total now let's see on the right hand
side i only have
2 hydrogens so if i want to balance that
i could multiply the water molecule
instead of
instead of just one here i could have
six and now this would be
12 hydrogen atoms so both the carbons
and the hydrogens are now balanced by
putting that six there i haven't messed
with the carbons
and now last but not least let's think
about the
oxygens here so on the left we have
six oxygens there and then another two
oxygens there so that's a total of eight
oxygens
and on the right i have 6
times 2 i have 12 plus another
6 oxygens so i have 18 oxygens on the
right hand side
and i only have 8 oxygens on the left
hand side so i have to increase the
number of oxygens on the left left-hand
side
so let's see this six you can see you
can imagine matches up with this six
so if i could somehow make this into 12
oxygens i'll be
good so the best way to make this into
12 oxygens is to multiply
this by 6. so let me do that
so if i put a 6 right over here i think
i'm all balanced
i have 6 carbons on both sides i have 12
hydrogens on both sides
and it looks like i have 18 oxygens
on both sides so i'm a fully balanced
equation here
so let me get a periodic table of
elements and i only need to think about
carbon hydrogen
and oxygen so for the sake of space let
me scroll down a little bit
i just need to look at this stuff over
here
and so let's first let's see hydrogen's
right up here
and we can see in this periodic table of
elements
it gives the average atomic mass but you
can also view that number
1.0 as its
molar mass so it's 1.008
grams per mole of hydrogen
now we can move on to carbon carbon
is 12.01 12.01
grams per mole of carbon
and then last but not least oxygen over
here
that is 16.
grams per mole of oxygen
and now we can use that information i
can now remove our periodic table of
elements
we can use this information to figure
out the molar masses
of each of these molecules so for
example
glucose right over here if we're talking
about
c6h12o6
how many grams per mole is that going to
be
gram how many grams is a mole of glucose
going to be
well it's six carbons 12 hydrogens and
six oxygens
so one way to think about it's going to
be six times this so it's going to be
six
times twelve 12.01
plus we have 12 times
1.008 plus
6 times 16.00 and then this is going to
be
grams per mole and this is going to be
equal to let's see
72.06
plus 12.096
plus 6 times 16 is 96.00
and of course all of this is in grams
per mole and so this is going to be
equal to let's see
72 plus 12 is 84
plus 96 is 180
180 point and let's see we have
60 thousands plus 96 thousands
which would be 156 thousandths so
and 156 thousands grams per mole and let
me make sure i got the significant
figures right
the 6 the 12 and 6 are pure numbers so i
can still i'm still good with this
and then when i add these numbers
together
i need to round to as much precision as
i have in the least one
so here i go up to the hundredths up to
the hundreds up to the thousands so i
need to round this actually to the
hundredths place
so this is going to be 180.16
grams per mole
of glucose and now let's think about the
other molecules
if we think about oxygen i'll do that
over here to save space
oxygen that's pretty straightforward a
molecular oxygen molecule just has two
oxygen atoms so it's going to be two
times this it's going to be 32.00
grams per mole and then carbon dioxide
carbon dioxide is going to be
it's two oxygens plus one carbon so it's
going to be this
plus one carbon so that's this plus
12.01 so that's 44.01
grams per mole and then last but not
least
we have the water and so
h2o this is going to be
two hydrogens so that's two times 1.008
so that's 2.016
plus an oxygen so that's going to be
2.016 plus 16
is going to be 18 point
once again we only go to the hundreds
place here so i'm going to round to the
hundredths place here
so 18.02 grams
per mole now the next step is to think
about
all right we're reacting with 25 grams
of glucose
how many moles of glucose is that
so we have 25.0
25
grams of glucose and we want to turn
this into moles of glucose
and we know the molar mass is 180.16
grams per mole or
we can multiply and say that this is for
every one mole
per mole it is 180.16
grams all i did is take the reciprocal
of this over here
and notice the grams will cancel with
the grams and i'll be left with
mole of glucose or moles of glucose is
going to be equal to 25.0
divided by 180.16
moles of glucose 25
divided by 1 180.16
is equal to this and let's see i have
three significant figures divided by
five significant figures so i'm going to
round to three significant figures
so 0.139
so this is approximately equal to 0.139
mole of glucose
now they say the first question is what
mass of oxygen
is required for a complete reaction of
this well for every mole of glucose we
need
six moles of molecular oxygen
and so we're going to need let me just
multiply that times six
so times six is equal to that and
remember i had three significant figures
so 0.833
so we're going to need 0
three 0.833 moles
of molecular oxygen and then i just
multiply that
times the molar mass of molecular oxygen
so times 32.00
grams per mole of molecular oxygen
0.833
times 32 is equal to that
if we go to three significant figures
it's 26
26.7
grams of oxygen
of molecular oxygen and so we've
answered the first part of the question
what mass of oxygen is required for
complete reaction so that's
this right over here and then the next
question is what masses of carbon
dioxide and water
in grams are formed remember for every
one mole of glucose
we needed six moles of molecular oxygen
and we produce six moles of carbon
dioxide and we produce
six moles of water so this is the number
of moles of glucose we
input into the reaction six times that
was this
so this is actually also the number of
moles of carbon dioxide
or water that we're going to produce so
if we take
our original 0.833
mole of carbon dioxide and i multiply
that times carbon dioxide's molar mass
44.01
grams per mole this is going to be
approximately equal to
0.833 times 44.01
is equal to three significant figures
36.7
grams 36.7
grams of carbon dioxide once again you
can see that the moles cancel with the
moles just as they did
before to give us grams of carbon
dioxide
and then last but not least we can do
that with the water 0.833
mole of h2o times its molar mass
times 18.02
grams per mole of water
is going to give us approximately 0.833
times 18.02
gives us three significant figures is
going to be 15.0
15.0 grams
of water and once again those moles
canceled out to give us the right units
and we're done which is pretty cool this
is really useful in chemistry
to be able to understand based on a
balanced chemical equation
to be able to understand hey if i have a
certain mass
of one of the inputs one of the things
that are one of the reactants
how much do i need of the other and then
how much mass of the
of the products am i actually going to
produce all of which we
just figured out